waiting waiting waiting
the high street and the wider economy
waiting for the restart
adam runs a chain of coffee shops in
london like many small business owners
he's had to adapt selling ground coffee
direct but he too
is waiting thinking about the end of
lockdown
i think it's very obvious that we need
to be able to see a reduction in the vat
as we have done recently for hospitality
that is going to really assist
hospitality as it starts to reopen its
doors
we also want to be able to see that
we've got support for those businesses
that are in bricks and mortar
so through business rates these are some
of the policies the treasury has been
considering ahead of this week's budget
the objective to kick-start the economy
so that when the waiting ends
the post-lockdown boom will be strong
and sustainable
i would scrap now the triple lock on
pensions because
the elderly i mean there are some
elderly people who've been very badly
hit by the crisis
but the the better off bet elderly the
comfortable elderly
have really done rather well you could
explain to people i've got to get
some more revenue can't just keep
printing and borrowing money
on this scale and it will hit us once
the crisis is over
unless we begin to tackle it now i
wouldn't put up taxes on business now
the awkward thing is that raising
corporation tax is one thing the
government seems quite keen on doing and
actually
some business people don't mind it's
wrong for business to create the
impression because
it would be wrong um that business isn't
prepared to play
its part in the recovery pretty much
every citizen
has been impacted and business is going
to have to pay part of the price too so
i think that balance can be struck the
shadow chancellor is cagey about
labour's position
but she has a message for rishi sunak
what i don't want to see
is a chancellor saying that he's
imposing immediate
increases in taxation right now and that
he's doing that for the sake of the
economy
when all the experts are saying that now
is the time
to focus on building back economic
recovery how about the argument for
balancing the books
well it looks strong if you look at
government borrowing which hit the
highest level
in the past fiscal year the highest
level in peacetime history
then again look at the cost of servicing
that debt and thanks to record low
interest rates
those debt interest costs are set to
drop to the lowest level ever
which might be an argument for borrowing
and spending more
the chancellor now putting the finishing
touches on this his second budget
will argue those costs could leap higher
whether he carries on splurging or uses
this week to begin balancing the books
there are risks in both directions ed
conway sky news